[Music]
do
so
[Music]
edition of
community and recreation um
i hereby declare the meeting open
and um just a little bit of housekeeping
at the beginning i would just like to
say that we will adjourn the meeting at
1 35
for to accommodate those who would like
to commemorate the
um
those that lost their lives in the
christchurch oscar attacks three years
ago
we will adjourn at 1 35
and come back at 1 45.
i think it's really important that we we
take a moment and
pay our respects for that um and other
housekeeping if you can please just use
the raised
raise hand function on the reactions at
the bottom there
um so that i can see if you want to
speak
and um with that
uh we'll just get on to the first order
of business
so um first order of business being
apologies
do we have any apologies at this point
i'm not i'm not aware of any
okay
um
we're missing
wendy i think
with that he's joining us today from an
email up this morning
yes
counselor when you said she will come up
to the council and join you shortly so
i'm sure she'll be there now
great oh and we've got phil there as
well
okay um is there somebody to move
that um wendy for late arrival and
in secondary moved by mayor dan and
seconded by
l
um
all in favor raise your hand
opposed i'm sure not okay
and
conflicts of interest are there any
conflicts of interest for today's
business
there appear to be none
okay and the confirmation of minutes
from our last meeting on the 14th of
december 2021
is there
any question about the
accuracy of those minutes
and if not
is there a mover and a seconder to move
those as a true and accurate record move
by robbie and seconded by mayor dan
um all in favor raise your hand
and
opposed okay that's passed
right are there any matters arising from
the minutes
there appear to be none
okay so that brings us on to
the deputation we have from
deirdre ryan is she oh yes there she is
hi davey
um well-being north canterbury
right deirdre um thank you for coming
today and welcome to our zooey
and um
just proceed when you're ready
oh kiara thank you um and thanks
everyone for having me along this
afternoon um i did actually send her
through a powerpoint presentation which
i'm
uh hoping it's landed there tessa is
there a way that that can be shared
um
we just got that
i can share screen assets if you
wouldn't mind
super helpful i had in my head we were
going to be on teams so i had a team's
lens on but um
i'll just have to find it if you can
hold for a sec thank you
so world tess is just um bringing that
up i'm deidre ryan i'm the manager for
community wellbeing north canterbury
trust um and we're just across the road
from most of you i don't know if you're
working from home or in your offices but
um
i could probably sprint down to you and
be sitting next to some of you uh about
two in a bit two minutes away so
on the first of march we moved to um new
premises which is uh in king street
which is right where the police had been
located so
um yeah moving in a pandemic it seems
like oh yeah of course of course we move
in a pandemic you know we've just had so
many unusual events in the last few
years haven't we so
um we're really happy to be here
and nice to be closer to our colleagues
at the council
um what i'm planning to do this
afternoon is i've just got a few short
slides and what i'd like to do is just
be able to provide an
update thanks tessa
um
on what we've been doing the services
that we offer uh and most of all
actually to thank you for your support
and your contribution to the work that
we're able to do here in our community
so tessa if you're able to help me by
sharing that screen
that's great please give me a yep
between slides yep sure thing
we've just got a title
screen come up there
there it is
there it is lovely thank you
um
so yeah
this is us community wellbeing north
canterbury trust um we're just in the
process of quite a few developmental um
tasks really um the first of those is
our um we've refreshed our branding so
you'll notice that our branding's
slightly different it's one of those
things where you someone says have you
had your hair cut or something different
we didn't want to change everything
but that's our new refresh branding
we're also updating our website
so that should be happening quite soon
along with our move so feel free to pop
down and see us too if you get a chance
so um just with the next slide um tessa
if you can
i thought um just by as a starting point
i'd uh wanted to have a look at your
long-term plan um and and the work that
we do and how it aligns with the
council's
uh long-term plan
the thing that i guess was there were a
few touch points where i could see where
our agency
does that
but i thought that the statement and
intent you have around people's needs
for mental and physical health and
social services emit was kind of where
we seem to sit comfortably
our mission is to strengthen well-being
in our community supporting our district
as a caring place to live
so i just wanted to acknowledge that
um by way of a background we pride
ourselves on being uniquely local um
we've been operating for more than 30
years now and we've been working hard to
create a resilient north canterbury
community
our reach is across the uh waimakariri
and hiranoi district so quite a large
geographical reach
the trust actually had its origins um
back in the late 80s in kaiapoi most of
you might know this um where it started
with a very small group of
people who wanted to do something about
marginalized people within that
community
and had actually quite a strong council
involvement in those early days with the
commencement of a community worker from
there we've grown um significantly both
in our reach and in the range of
services that we offer and we've kind of
um
morphed and you know uh traveled
alongside as these organizations evolve
i've been with the trust for 11 years
now can you believe that dan
when i started dan was um
dan was actually the chair of the of the
trust
and i still remember vividly on the my
second day at work which was the day of
the february earthquakes i was about to
go and have lunch with my new boss
but of course that didn't happen
so we had other things to do that day as
it turns out
but the trust does have a long and
trusted history
of working within
the district
and is known as a trusted face within
the district as well we've expanded our
reach largely into the hiranui district
quite significantly recently
had a count up last night we have 38
paid employees now and 60 dedicated
volunteers so we are a reasonably
big organisation now
operational bases we have three of those
um in at 200 king street which is where
i am right now
27 seal street at caipor community
support which of course is a council um
facility we're really grateful to be
able to base ourselves there and provide
a range of services
including our food bank and other
services there and then we have karanga
my early learning center which is based
next to the young parents college at
kaibu high school
thanks tessa
so these are the uh free services that
we offer across the whole of north
canterbury
so we have kalangamai early learning
center as i say
the role there is full at the moment so
we have
over 30 tamariki enrolled there
and we provide
transport for children to come to and
from
the centre every day
we have kaipu community support where we
have our food bank
we are
the food bank has been there for several
years we also provide offices for other
agencies to be able to provide outreach
services such as community law
also pegasus health
use the rooms there so we we're kind of
a
an outreach base for other agencies
which helps to bring more services out
into
our district
we have two north canterbury social
workers
we work closely with oranga tamariki in
that work
we have our mana aki
initiative which is stronger for
tomorrow that's a dhb contract and that
is working
with young tamariki in years one to
eight in supporting and strengthening
their well-being
we also work with our rangatahi our
young people
and um through that we offer a
counselling and mental wellbeing support
service
called manu kareri manu kaleri means
soaring bird
and alongside that we offer specialist
alcohol and drug support for um
rangatahi as well through our early
start program
so these are all trained counsellors
that we have in that service mana aki is
a mixture of social workers and
counsellors and the north canterbury
social workers are registered social
workers
we provide restorative justice services
which is an adult service we receive um
referrals from the courts
uh to work through a restorative justice
program that's that particular service
actually originated with waimakuri
district council back in the day it
would have been about the mid to late
90s i think that was initiated
and we were fortunate to be able to be
offered that service to pick that up so
we now have a direct contract with the
ministry of justice for that
we work really closely particularly
through our food bank with the food
secure network
and
which is you know you're probably quite
quite aware i'm sure tess has kept you
abreast of all of the work that's going
there that i'm really significant
collaboration fantastic work so we do
our best to contribute to that
um
most recently we have employed uh two
next steps facilitators um these are
specifically to support people who have
been affected by covert nineteen
um and so we have um
two people who are working in those
roles we have ave tulamana who is in the
hiranui and we have renault stevens
who's working for us here in the
waimakariri and i'm about to appoint
another person as well
so we will have two full fte
doing that work um they are getting
really busy um as siq is ramping up as
of yesterday actually things are really
getting very busy in that space and
again we're really grateful to be
considered to be able to offer those
that service
we have a hiranui specific family worker
that's
really we've been able to secure some
funding for that um since the hiranoi
earthquake earthquakes it's taken a
couple of years to beat that down but we
do have someone who works just in the
hiranui
um and finally we also host um social
services waimakariri facilitator that's
nikki carter
so one of the things we like to do as an
agency is to provide
a
base and host roles
for organizations that might not
necessarily have
be incorporated societies or have leg be
a legal entity but we can host the roles
on host a role on behalf of them so that
they can get on with the work so that's
nicki carter who's doing a lot of work
closely with the council again
particularly in this covert environment
thanks tessa
i thought you i might like to see a
story of hope
it's always good to be able to share
some of the real ones that we managed to
get out of the work that we do um so in
january this year starting on the first
day back at work actually fifth of
january we partnered with
a company called surf wise i don't know
if some of you like know tammy mason
who's an absolute legend in leadership
development and working with young
people through
surfing in the ocean
so we she partnered up with some of our
clinical team
and we provided um some some
oh i think it was i'm just trying to
think it was three consecutive days
for um young people for young people
from madagaki so the primary school age
kids in the morning the rangatahi in the
afternoon to go through a whole
experience of learning how to surf not
only learning how to surf but learning
about themselves through that process
it was hugely successful we're just
trying to secure more money so we can
continue with this and we had our
clinicians in the water
with the young people so it was really
quite a very experiential very powerful
process for them
and it's something we really want to
continue so you can see
i think the smiles just show it all
actually these are young people who ask
you know that's they struggle sometimes
but you can see that feedback you know i
can plug my feet into the sand feel calm
and happy like i belong
i'm proud of how i've done finding a way
to connect with my inner self
i struggle with depression i've learnt
so many new coping strategies and it's
taught me things can be really hard
sometimes but you can always get through
like isn't that incredible learning um
and insight for these young people
particularly for our community where we
have sustained um you know several
unexpected losses over the last 12
months
sadly
so i thought you might like to hear
about that
one of the things i thought you might be
interested in also is just having a look
at our funding picture
so you can see that
we get a significant amount of our
funding through contracts we work
closely with the government and have
multiple contracts with multiple
parts of government to provide services
we work closely with oranga tamariki the
ministry of education ministry of
justice
the dhb
um and and others
um you can also see that we have um
we're always looking for grants that's
our funding gap really you can see where
the get is we get 73 odd percent through
contracts the rest of it we have to find
for ourselves
um and i really at this point do want to
acknowledge the huge help and support
that um waimakariri district council
provide to enable us to
stay here you know to stay embedded to
keep doing the work even when it it gets
tough and it does mean a lot to us to be
able to
receive that funding so thank you very
much
next one i think tessa um just to let
you know that we we collaborate pretty
widely um we're part of the together
hironui
um collaboration obviously because we
host the ssw facilitator
nikki um i'm employ her and support her
as well and we support the
social services waimakariri as much as
we can we attend pastoral care meetings
across the whole district
and also our clinical team leader um
antoinette louis
attends odangatamariki panels so we're
working alongside our most vulnerable
now our higher highest level of risk
within the district we work closely with
our local business partners and this is
something that we've really tried to
rank up ramp up so
we have louise leach who's our
storyteller she um
puts up our facebook posts she writes
media releases and helps to tell the
story about the work that we do and but
most importantly to show the con
where the contributions that people make
where that actually goes and how it
helps us
so the local business partners include
bailey's and they helped us with a
cairns for a cause
promotion last last year um ray white
helped us a lot particularly around
christmas time
and stadium cars have been very
supportive in helping us to secure
good vehicles so we can get people out
around the district
and also just wanting to acknowledge the
clubs that help us as well so we have
seroptimists
help us out a lot um lions and rotary
have also been massive contributors and
you know even um
uh the leos club in at ranger high
school did some fundraising for us so
some of that's slowed down quite a bit
for obvious reasons they you can't run
the the fundraising events that we hope
to this year uh but we just keep on
plugging away anyway
so um i think that pretty much wraps us
up there's just one more slide there
um and just to reiterate our
appreciation of um the support that you
put towards um contributing to our
services
so that's that's it from me happy to
answer any questions that you might have
or
thank you so much for that deirdre um
are there any questions
mayor dan
to believe it was eleven years you said
diedrich so um gosh it's gone by quickly
um
i think i wasn't i think i hit here in
those days so
we won't talk about what's changed for
us
um a really great presentation deidre
you're talking about the funding climate
you're in
i was interested in the pie charts so
obviously relying on quite a lot in the
discretionary field and if i missed it
before in your presentation
what are your current challenges in that
space and
um because i know that you have to work
really hard to achieve funding every
year
and how are you trekking in the
discretionary space you're still picking
up that support sufficiently
to meet all your need or are you
finding it a bit of a struggle
um are you just interested to have that
picture by the way um
your new office looks really great down
the road i saw the new branding i
wanted to say well done to you and the
team for all that you do
thank you
oh it's a it's an ongoing struggle um i
think that the struggle really is around
uh lack of certainty sometimes so to be
able to keep our good people
we need to be able to offer um you know
long-term contracts
employment contracts
that's that's definitely a struggle for
us the last year has been difficult we
have as i say we haven't been able to um
you know there are some uh groups and
organizations who would like to
fundraise for us on our behalf which is
fantastic really but you know
those events have been cancelled or
postponed
because we can't have gatherings um
it is always a struggle um
we're just trying to um
we just keep on working at it really
yeah
so i think that um just things like
finding you know that there are things
that um as you would be well aware dan
from your time with with the um the
trust that
the funding that we get from from
government um it is it is improving a
little bit in terms of them
understanding that we have an
infrastructure to support but things
like um paying for our vehicles um
paying for salaries like the likes of my
salary and the other operations team
um isn't covered that none of that is
covered through contract work um through
contract
funds sorry um you know our rent our
laptop that i'm talking to you on all of
those things that are all the glue that
keeps us operating efficiently and
safely that's where we have to keep uh
plugging away
so you know we're pretty trying to be
pro we're prudent with our funding um we
we run a lean
lean operation
and whenever we do get a chunk of
opportunity to be able to
provide more services we do and i think
that the hiranoi family work is an
example of that that's not funded
through any contracts that's something
where we really want that to happen
yeah
so i hope that's answered your question
no it does didn't i recognize that
you've got there and i wish we could do
more um
and
it's there anything from anyone else
yeah me
i'm in the office oh hello wendy
my macaroon district council would you
like to
thank speak um tessa sorry
i can hear you typing
then i need to mute don't i
i wasn't gonna say
okay
you very much for that report it was
very good dude i've just had to come up
to the office because i have no interest
at home at the moment
um
just i just want to go back over things
i'm sorry you had you said you had 38
paid employees and where there's some
part where they part-time full-time what
it's about
yeah sorry sorry wendy
we've got probably 34 fte
right
yep so some of those are part-time
fun okay okay
um and so
with what's going on at the moment in in
our area with with all the extra
stresses and and things that put on to
the community
um how are your staff coping on or do
you need more staff or you know just
just want to know where your
your board thinking is
um i i don't think we'll be getting any
smaller
it seems to be happening that as
as there's more need we're being asked
to do more which we're really happy to
do
um
the staff are doing quite well um we
tend to try as much as we can to walk
the talk if we call ourselves community
wellbeing north canterbury trust we try
to behave that way
um
and so all in all this i think the team
are doing quite well um
we just make sure that they're taking
they're taking breaks and managing their
own well-being as much as as we can
um
one thing that i didn't mention actually
was um
you'll be aware that we have had a
really rough time out here in north
canterbury with a lot of southern losses
and um
those of you who might have had a
connection with some of those people you
know just wanting to extend my my
condolences for that
one of the things we've been working on
quite closely is the postvention
initiative and particularly working with
young people who might be at risk of
harming themselves
and as a result of that work the dhb
have approached us to see if we can
employ a well-being coordinator to work
with
young people who might be identified as
being at risk
so you know i guess that's the beauty of
and why i love working for community
wellbeing i've always loved working for
community wellbeing
is that we can take an approach that is
flexible and responsive
so that when issues come up in our
community if we can get hold of some
resources we can do our best to make it
happen
thank you thank you very much for that
um appreciate that you've mentioned
about the um
the at-risk youth because that's so
vitally important thank you we're making
hoping to make an appointment there in
the next week or two so we can have
somebody on the ground
doing that work and i'll call over to
see you in your office
be lovely you're welcome anytime thank
you
deity thank you very much for
that great report and thank you so much
for all the work that you and your team
do it really is valued in our community
and
you know we really can't thank you
enough for being there for for those
that need you when they need you
um
and also i'd just like to make a quick
comment but the lovely lady on the back
page of your report is my friend esther
very nice
so um yes anyway thank you thank you so
much for your time very much appreciated
and um
thank you very much so i will take my
leave now and let you uh continue with
your afternoon wonderful thank you thank
you
guys so um moving on to item five i'm
not sure how we're going to go with
having that for 10 minutes and then
breaking
what are our thoughts here guys
um shall we just get a start on that and
see how we go
okay
all right well then um so moving on to
item 5.1 south bay park pavilion martin
mcgregor you are on
and that is tab three in your diligent
oh can't hear you martin
i hate it when that happens
looking better can you hear me now yes
well done thank you thank you uh nice to
be here this is my first uh community
recreation committee so
yeah fantastic to be here um so the
purpose of this report is to this
committee to receive the feasibility
study and also for the committee to
support staff moving forward with the
outcomes of that it's a feasibility
study so i'll start i'll take the
reporters
i'll go through some of the key findings
just to join everybody's uh memory of
the report so this feasibility study was
commissioned on the back of an ltp
solution from southport community sports
club
around financial difficulties so having
an operational cost of their buildings
located in south
um some of the key findings um from the
study was that there was bound to be a
need for facilities at this location
about the present and future um that
these buildings were not for purpose
the recommendation moving forward was to
demolish the rebuilding facility
the ownership of facilities the
southport community support club
indicated that they do not want to own
or operate the facilities going forward
um and so therefore future operating
models need to be investigated both
around
management and also um ownership and
capital and problem to those
um
now the funding that we currently have
24k sitting in the draft
implant for support of this group
staff we have been working with an
alternative funder
to secure their funding we have a
application in
at the moment the decision on that is
marketing field page mark so if that was
successful
required so that's just an update on
that situation so i'm happy to be
questioned
all right who's up first with questions
and al
thank you thanks madam um one big
question i've got
in
item
what is it
if the um demolition costs
to 200 grand for the pavilion and round
figures and a hundred grand for the
i find that absolutely unbelievable i
ran it past a contractor mate of mine
just just
obviously a very high level and said how
much to pull these down and he said oh
you know 50 for the pavilion and 30 for
the changing how the hell do we get
to hundred thousand to demolish two
buildings that are only the size of a
two-story house
so it had to check in detail with the
consultant around what uh where they
sourced those prices from
um in it but certainly as we work
forward going uh looking through the
options uh all that information will be
able to be fixed out and raises
so yeah i don't have the exact answer
thank you
chris would you like to say something to
that
uh yeah just quickly um
they're really really high level
estimates at the moment um
that um have to be
high with large contingencies to take
into consideration um things like
asbestos in the building and whether or
not that would be there and we don't
know that um so at the moment it's the
sort of worst case scenario around um
what the demolition cost would be um
they're quite old buildings so things
like asbestos may be in the building
and therefore they'd have to be
parts of the building taking to cape
valley and things like that as opposed
to
if that's not the case then that's
awesome then then it is cheaper but it's
a worst case scenario in the report at
the moment
bearing in mind that the report was also
is also now a few months old and costs
would have increased since then as well
yeah i just i just note across the
asbestos thing is on top of that again
there's a contingency on top of that
figure for asbestos if we find it yeah
the um the consultants
use a quantity surveyor to
um give them their figures and um we're
happy to check those again
thank you um paul
yeah um my concerns are
how many other buildings in the
situation like that um
probably need um and the area needs to
be demolished and rebuilt with some
million dollar buildings at the moment
because that to me
looks to me and i've been inside quite
often as um
a relatively okay building for um some
of the other sporting clubs and all that
would love to have that type of building
and size buildings and all that so how
many others in our district are we may
be looking at the same scenario of um
um demolishing and rebuilding
um yeah i'll grab that one uh paul
it's it's a conversation that we've
actually been having with uh
with richard lindsey at rsl um just in
terms of
looking at our buildings and um
you'll note within the report that
martin had suggested that we need to
look at a network uh plan for our
community facilities
that will probably iron out some of
those uh concerns because for us the
biggest burden that we've currently got
for our volunteer um
our volunteers at some of these sports
clubs is the fact that they're trying to
keep some of these buildings and some of
these assets viable but they're also
looking for ways to keep
bars and other things running which
might not necessarily be required in
terms of actually just the club
delivering what they deliver
um in terms of the quantum at the moment
uh with the renewals program that andy
and his team are going through we feel
that we might actually get on top of
that um especially with the the way that
they're looking at doing the asset
management
um it's going to be a lot more thorough
and actually a lot more detailed around
what it is that we need to do with the
buildings that we currently control
uh in terms of some of the private
buildings yes there will no doubt be
some out there that
will have an issue and
look that's around some of the changes
in legislation as well it's
it's getting harder and harder for
community groups to be able to access
funding because some of the funding
streams that we've traditionally had
um have
kind of come into question from an
ethics perspective
if we look at lotteries and
a few other sources like that you know
there's
counter arguments to to try and reduce
those so
there's a lot of work that we need to do
around actually answering that question
paul but it's certainly one that we have
posed to not just the consultants also
within the team but actually to the
wider industry as well
because that's potentially a burden that
we could have right across new zealand
in terms of our community facilities
and what we do going forward chris
it's a good question paul um i'll just
um
a bit of background um
since i've been
uh at the council we've taken ownership
of the
gatekeepers lodge on hoka domain
ownership of rangiora museum
and we're currently looking at
the
potential purchase of the ibud street
building
with the intention of um that not being
in our ownership for a long period of
time so uh and also um the weymouth
united football building on maria
andrews we've um
uh essentially worked with the club to
to get rid of that building because that
was um unaffordable and unusable for
them as well um so there are a number of
buildings out there um we we know of uh
even more in terms of the clarkville
hall the swananoa um hall where they are
sifton hall these are all privately
owned halls where we make contributions
both as annual grants and in the past
also
capital grants
for maintenance et cetera to reflect the
fact that if that building wasn't there
then we would likely have to have a
building in that location so
we need to do that piece of work to find
out
exactly where we should be
providing funding and where there might
be shortfalls now you did mention paul
around other um
sports clubs potentially wanting a
building as large as this
the the report from rsl is pretty clear
that the building's not for purpose
there's a lot of maintenance that hasn't
been done in the building it doesn't
meet current requirements for
um sports clubs to be able to use in an
efficient way to actually
get back some money to pay the costs
that they have i mean they have to go
into the building and and light the fire
a couple of hours before they actually
have a community group going to use it
and with the
lack of volunteers they just can't
afford um to be able to do that so it's
pretty clear that it's not fit for
purpose great question as to whether or
not there's others thanks paul
yeah so
to answer the question um
from my starter should we have a report
on seeing the priority of what type of
buildings for example you mentioned
museum building that's not fit for
purpose whatsoever
and um
which is priority on some of these
buildings because there's numerous ones
around and and how many millions
would that add up to um
for the council left to budget to
replace some of these um it's not a
small task it's a major one so i think a
report is needed on all of our buildings
and a dollar value
um
putting on to it in a priority list it's
my thoughts
um i'll take that as a question um and i
uh agree with you and that's why the
report that we've got at the moment
identifies a bit of a community
facilities network plan which actually
says you know what is the state of our
community facilities we've already done
all the work with the community of
facilities we own in terms of
understanding the state that they're in
and the replacement cost of all the
assets and that has gone into our
ford program as part of the last
long-term plan to make sure that they
are kept up to the right standard
um however this report suggests that
we
continue to support the south brook
sports club while doing that piece of
work up until the long-term plan and
that long-term plan will be the period
at which we can come to council and say
hey look here's here's all the
information we know here's where south
brook fits into that um picture of
expenditure across our district to make
sure that we have the right community
facilities in the right place for the
right people i'm noting that we've
already got some work to
um that we've done to throw into that um
with the
pegasus ravens ravenswood community
facilities network plan which was
already completed for the long term plan
but there's more work to be done there
absolutely so this report will help us
bring that back for the long term plan
thank you is that helpful right um i
think following on from that you know i
i take paul's point that um you know
that's actually quite a inexpensive
expenditure we're talking about the
thick end of 3.8 million dollars
and
those other community facilities are
probably not collectively worth that
much
what opportunities do we have for a
public-private partnership or something
like that to um
to replace a building like this because
that's quite a substantial amount that
that report's calling for i and i do
note that they talked about in the um
in the report a
um they
mentioned somerset for instance or you
know some bigger companies that might be
able to help out
do we have any idea with that
i think certainly if we were
[Music]
thank you because i i i would note that
there are lots of other clubs other
rugby clubs you can pick any any number
of them that um have provided their own
facilities and their own upgrades and
fundraise for those things and built
those things and maintained them so
it
it is something that we definitely need
some more work on there yes grant
um yeah and look they're they're really
good points as well and um just had a
conversation with there with andy so
we've noted down um
we've noted down that feedback as well
because that had formed part of what we
would want to put into a brief as well
for a consultant working on that plan
and certainly some of the things that
we'd want to address within that as well
so that's good feedback for us
um hey guys so i just realized the time
it is 139
so for those that
wish to
go out to the front of here at council
and want to
commemorate the christchurch terror
attacks
otherwise we can have a moment of
silence here and come back at 1 45.
[Music]
it falls in the middle of proceedings
guys but
it's the right thing to do
so
um
who was speaking
i think we were open for more questions
nikki um wendy did you have a question
yes i do please um looking at these uh
this this pavilion that you're wanting
to um
remove
um
that is that building um fit for
multi-use and multi
like for men and women or is it just
really mainly for the men
because a lot of these older types of
buildings are not suitable for for women
so if you're referring
uh
is really really poor quality
unfortunately um so
um
i'll jump in and answer the question and
grant will be able to do the same and
maybe you can go and he's already gone
to steal someone else as i imagine um
so wendy the one the the one which has
been identified in the reporters is
uh is something which is just a a plan
of what best practice would be at the
moment the current facility doesn't
um the change rings are not good for
both male and female and they do need to
be upgraded to be able to actually
provide proper changing rooms especially
with an increase in female participation
in sports like rugby uh that is really
really important um but what the what
any future building might look like is
still subject to uh would to still be
the subject of lots of um design work in
in the future um years down the track
but would consider that
the other question i want to ask please
is
with the funding and
really going towards women in sport
would that be helpful
uh there has been as part of the cricket
world cup there was some money floating
around for
um helping um with
fit outs of changing rooms and you'll
know that the
canopy country cricket at main power
over there got some funding
i don't think there's any other funding
available at the moment but it'll be
part of the funding strategy to um uh
shake every service we can um find to
try and get some funding to to assist um
noting that the building's actually not
ours
they're both owned by the south brook
sports club and historically we haven't
provided club rooms for for anybody else
we've provided changing rooms
infrastructure parking those sorts of
things but not club rooms so whatever we
do to keep consistent with our levels of
service in the past
we would have to um have a partnership
with the south brook sports club and
then um absolutely other um potential
public-private partnerships sponsorship
those sorts of things but there will
have to be a funding strategy done and
getting that funding especially for the
club may take several years
thank you
um philip did you have another question
uh thanks nikki uh hopefully you can
hear me um what sort of ability to that
those sports clubs have for funding
uh that's one question and secondly when
you look around the district there are
other club club rooms that really you
could say are not overly fit for purpose
thirdly a lot of the users at
south brook appear to be touch rugby and
my experience with my grandchildren are
they turn up play the game and go they
have very little requirement to use club
rooms
so
in terms of a hierarchy or priority
where does this sort of fit
so sorry i've just reinvented myself as
grant mccloud to fix the sound issue
in terms of access for funding they have
the same access i guess as any community
group which is out there seeking to
build a facility through the various um
trusts and and gaming in in that regard
um
so
in terms of it being
fit for purpose um this facility as
chris had mentioned earlier um is
struggling with its functionality which
affects their revenue and so the burning
platform we have for this particular
building is that they are falling short
with their operational costs and that's
why they are seeking um systems from
from council so that is what's pushing
us this particular building to push this
building forward uh over others there
are other aging club rooms uh around the
place but this one wasn't purpose built
for a sports club it was moved here from
another location so it's not
particularly functional it makes it
difficult for them to
earn revenue and then meet their
operating costs and sorry is there a
third part to your question but i may
not have covered
i just
commented on the number using it and to
what degree are the club rooms required
for touch rugby for example
yeah so touch rugby uh absolutely being
a summer sport um and junior touch rugby
in particular uh and i know what you're
referring to my kids have played there
as well um but senior touch rugby uh
maybe use it for a drink or a function
afterwards
but particularly in the winter months
with rugby club and the way that they
run their sport after match functions
etc that's its main use and so the
report did
assess that and had found that there was
an existing and future need
for the facility but yeah i agree with
your point in regards to touch
right
are there any other questions
is there a secondary
so moved by mayo dan seconded by l
would you like to speak to the motion
dan um yes i support the recommendation
firstly can i say that i think rsl have
done a really good job this is the path
that
we set them off on um calling for this
uh about a year or two ago
we was clear that
south brook were certainly going to have
ongoing issues
with respect to
the continuity you know they were
struggling with
committee members
they
were struggling with this facility it
has rightly been mentioned um by chris i
think an answer before one of the big
issues is once you start to touch this
building you then got to bring it up to
code and you're spending a lot of money
on a facility
that this won't be
um sorry someone um
in the victory and i'm just uh i think
it might be ul
um
sorry manche just um
just it's not fit for purpose and so
this this direction is not committing
the council
um to
build a new facility but it is simply
saying that the study has concluded that
metal being treated as part of
um
future work that the council will need
to look at doing in preparation for
our next ltp
it's timely that that's considered as
well in the broader context of what
might be needed in that community
it's a growing area down there there
isn't a lot of facilities in the
immediate area
it's timely to consider that and
some of the concepts that are in there
certainly show that um
you know two-story facility like that's
not really required uh any any any uh
into the future so it was the old town
and country club that was built moved on
there
um years and years ago and it's just
sort of been a
an ongoing meta that they are the club's
been settled with um and the new club
that's there and they've got good people
like peter freeman and then in place
that certainly are well connected in our
community and i'm sure we'll do their
absolute best to make sure that um
all the cans are actually tins are
threshold and it won't be just the right
pair that's um sell this if that's the
conclusion we've come to but in the
intro i support our supporting the club
and their operating costs
um as we have done in the last few years
because they're just struggling
and
it's a similar conversation that we had
this morning with respect to another
matter once you lose the volunteers
from it and you lose those people
operating in it falls on the council for
their own sooner partner with volunteers
and clubs to achieve a better outcome
this year gives us a really good basis
and the club a good basis in which to
build upon
and
they need a feasibility study in order
to
achieve partnership funding from the
discretionary sector so it gives them a
good basis as well so i support work
thank the staff for all that they've
done in terms of pulling this together
and working with rsl in the club to get
to this point
thank you dan al would you like to speak
to that yeah just just briefly yeah i
still i'll support this the um
with some with some reservations with
some caution you know we're between a
rock and a hard place here where no one
wants to see this thing fall over but we
i worry about the precedent of this um
the council paying for club rooms um
and and the ownership clause g and this
thing they they were the clubs already
said they did whatever we do they don't
want to be on the ownership i think that
needs a lot more a lot more thought and
consideration you know post earthquake
um thinking of the examples kaiapoi
league club um we didn't pay for their
new club rooms they went out they
actually bought and sold houses to raise
funds for their club and ditto the
tennis club we're not paying for their
pavilion we pay for the courts i think
i'm right hockey club same um
chris has alluded to this it's almost a
whole
whole ethos change the the thought of of
whether whether or not council needs
which would be with a rate payer should
be paying for a club that is struggling
to survive as a club and
and again rugby you know it's been a
religion for decades um in the in the
past the council would would have
supported a rugby club without even
thinking about it because it's not even
the number one sport in the country now
and it's numbers are dropping away
although women women numbers are
increasing but overall it's not it's not
the major it's not the major sport it
used to be so there's a lot of a lot of
the the team need to do a lot of work
before we commit to this sort of thing
in the meantime happy to support the
club um stay with us keeping its nose
above water and we'll see where we go
for for the ltp thank you
thank you
i'm robbie
robbie would you like to speak
sorry about that i struggle with
technology
um
you know i was around when this project
was uh initiated
and
at the beginning there were misgivings
on the council table however they
presented a a very good case which is
why we
gave a loan of 150 000
and for some time they were able to pay
that and the club was successful
and it became even more successful with
the combination of south brook rugby
club and rang your rugby club and of
course the issues ran you're ahead with
the pavilion down at the amp grounds
then
[Music]
started to turn a little bit to casted
and they struggled to pay back the loan
it's telling me my internet connection
is is unstable so
um
tell me if it's it's not going i'll just
video is it going anymore probably it
gives you a better better signal
we've heard we've heard most of it but
um yeah if you do turn off your video
it might help
yeah try it try again
so
again um with
we were able to to recommence repayments
but then things like insurance
increasing rates a whole number of
things plus the fact that we were
looking at curtains that needed
replacing we needed furnishings replaced
and all these things we we couldn't do
and it just spiraled down and down and
down
getting back to the nuts and bolts of
the the report
and
it's
clear in the report that it's notes
notes notes notes so it's a discussion
for the future as to
what may be replaced but what is for
certain is that we don't want to keep on
having to put in 26 and next year it'll
probably be 30 000
into into something it's a sinking hole
um the place does need to be um
demolished
um so that we're not investing that that
money
and it's not an investment actually as i
say it's just the sinking hole that
we're throwing it into so
um we do need to look at
removing it having the discussion about
what replaces it how that's going to be
funded um i accept the comments that
that
else just made over a sport bearing in
mind anything that would go there would
be multi multi-sport
and not just for for saracens spray bee
football club
so obviously you know i support the
report
thank you robbie would anyone else like
to speak
yes please
i'll just grab wendy first therefore
thank you
yes
we need to be looking after this because
that south brooklyn area right around
there is is growing in population
and the different types of sporting
facilities that could be available at
that ground is actually really important
that grounds a large ground and can
accommodate for quite a number of things
uh just a question robbie the uh
the cricket club is that quite strong at
the moment
no it's no it's not that's another sport
that's that's struggling and uh cricket
was a partner with saracens however
saracens brought cricket out because
they could not afford uh to to be a
member there was a cost involved for the
clubs and being a member and quicker
found themselves in a position where
they couldn't afford it and this year
they've really struggled to field a
premier team
thank you
i'm paul
do you wish to say something yeah yeah
i'm just concerned about um it seems um
interesting here some of the smaller
clubs around the area seem to fundraise
and and um get on with
running their complexes and everything
with volunteers yet the bigger
areas they've got lots of players and
all that
struggled to actually get done
volunteers and um to do things and all
that they just
seem to want to hand out rather than
a hand up help themselves so
i'm getting concerned
and we've honey
will take it off with them
and um but this group should be
supporting themselves and fundraising i
know people in this same hall who wanted
us here um
for a 21st and they got turned down no
no um we're too busy to do that and the
halls nothing was happening so
sometimes i think it's just more than um
yeah i just i'm concerned
thank you for that input
all right
is there anyone else that wishes to
speak
okay without further ado then i'll put
it to the vote um oh sorry oh sorry
write a reply excuse me
forgive me mr mayor um would you like to
use your writer for you
just very briefly i think noting the
comments have been made there's no
commitment at this stage all it's doing
is noting is is robbie rightly observed
and it's as i mentioned in my comments
there's a lot of work to be done and i'm
sure of the feedback that from
colleagues today staff will make sure
they're reflected back to the club
there's going to be to be a commitment
towards fundraising
and
in a program for them to advance this
but this is an important part of it if
they don't have a feasibility study
uh which they've now got
uh they can't it's a chicken and egg
situation they can't actually apply to
major funders for support so this now
gives them an opportunity to progress
with the further steps and we will keep
briefed along the way
i'm sure that there will be a request
that will come for a funding partnership
at some particular point in time that's
something i've got an open mind to for
the future but
like others have said we will need to
just be absolutely clear about what the
purpose is
and that there's a funding partnership
there in
[Music]
they've done their work in that space
and i just hope our staff can work and i
know they will work alongside the club
to make sure that um they understand
that and that they're starting to work
on that program and how they might
achieve that it's an important it's an
important club it certainly offers a lot
in our community and and so that's the
basis in which i've been supporting them
over the last number of years with the
work that we're doing to help them with
the operational costs to get the
feasibility studies so they're now in
this position to go out and see what
they can do with that and where their
future rests so
i have no hesitation supporting us today
and i hope colleagues will do the same
thank you dan
this is a very complex situation with a
lot of avenues that need to be pursued
and a lot of water to flow under the
bridge yet
i will put the
recommendations a through j to the vote
those in favor please raise your hand
opposed
i declare the motion passed
thank you
um and thank you staff for your
support and
of the club and for your report um
there's a lot of work coming in that
work stream all right and moving on to
our next item of business the covered 19
social recovery update
so that's
item 5.2 on tab 4.
tessa you and i'll remember to mute
after this one
um so this report provides an overview
of community team activity
related to the key project areas for
covert 19 social recovery and those
project areas are detailed in the draft
recovery plan
which was prepared in 2020
the period this period is from august
through to february 2022
some of this relates directly to
business as usual for the community team
however you will be aware of the
significant progress on three key
projects food security which is
co-facilitated by community development
staff and social services waimakariri
and the associated kaiapoi
hub project and also the next steps
support and information website and
facilitation service and in deidre's
presentation you would have seen that
well-being north canterbury umbrella the
next steps facilitator roles employ
those and they work closely with
community development staff and the
covered response
um
you'll see in the attachment a report on
the food secure project and that was
extremely
posi received extremely positive
feedback from the ministry of social
development
um
and that report was prepared by our
community development facilitator you'll
see that it showcases the incredible
work that's been done in the area of
food security
which puts us in a really good place
when we start to look at developing a
hub and kaiapoi
item 4.3 details progress on these key
projects but also the more general
covert recovery priorities and this
builds on the work that began in early
2020 just prior to the nationwide
lockdowns
compared to two years ago uh
our community is in an even stronger
place to ensure that this important
recovery work is effectively planned and
delivered
and that we now have a designated social
recovery staff member within the
community team
who can make sure that covert specific
projects can be planned facilitated and
delivered well
and also the the employment of the next
step facilitators has
just been marvelous in terms of making
sure
that
people are responded to in a really
holistic manner when they have often
complex
welfare needs
uh related to either the emotional or
the financial stressors of the covered
event
um so there have been a few success
factors and i guess communication has
been key
and our strength is really in how
connected our district is people can
pick up the phone people can send an
email we can quickly have a conversation
get something done it's really easy to
get people around the table talking
brainstorming identifying emerging
issues identifying emerging
opportunities and then community
development staff can work on them to
see those come into fruition
and communication has and connection has
increased over the past year as we've
sought to bring in a wider range of
community support organizations
and services
to sit around the table
so the role of the community team in
forward planning right from the start
the 2020 lockdowns has continued as the
pandemic has evolved
and we've been able to anticipate urgent
and potential issues and then work with
our networks including social services
waimakariri the health advisory group
the food bank network and local welfare
committee to plan
and co-facilitate local responses
and sometimes this is delivered through
increasing local service provision
uh
via the likes of wellbeing north
canterbury and a really good example of
that was identifying that that someone
who could facilitate that holistic
response would be really useful and that
that could be managed and delivered by
wellbeing north canterbury with some
good funding
and that allows community development
staff to work with other partners on the
development of the complementary
self-help website that will make sure
that people are empowered to help
themselves as we move further into the
recovery phase
so uh with respect to the current siq or
in-home quarantine situation
staff have worked with the social
services waimakariri facilitator and
they have developed some clear triage
pathways
so that welfare related issues that
can't be handled by ministry of social
development who are the lead for welfare
recovery are triaged essentially via the
next facilitators
and then with community development
staff covering after hours and weekend
responses
and they're things like
uh the need for
food parcels assistance with acquiring
food online through supermarkets where
digital literacy is an issue
um
perhaps assistance with animals uh
assistance with whanau members giving
them things to do and libraries have
been great and partnering to get some of
those resources in place also
so finally going forward you will note
in item 4.5 that staff continue to work
with our community partners to identify
and respond to emerging covert related
issues affecting local residents
it's fair to say that our district's
recovery will go well beyond the end of
the covered response
and you'll see when you look through
this list that the building of
resilience addressing of mental health
and substance related harm will be
really important
we're also going to want to support
local business owners who are suffering
the same stressors as everyone else but
while trying to keep their businesses
float
so there's a pastoral care element and
we've had conversations with enterprise
north canterbury to see how we might
frame
pastoral care for businesses in the next
wee while and of course we've had
something of a social divide
in our community
particularly in the past six months but
but prior to that around vaccines and
now vaccine passports
and there will be a bit of work to do in
bringing the people back together
and healing a few wounds and the art
strategy project that's currently
underway will be an integral part of
that so um
save highlighting those few points i
will take the report as read and happy
to answer any questions
thank you tessa
have we got any questions out there team
yes
wendy thank you teaser thank you very
much for that report it was very good
i'm just uh interested in um
the um
well-being series for men um
and focusing on suicide and mental
prevention of mental health so um
i know that they did it last year
they're going to be doing much the same
sort of thing this year putting on a
breakfast or this is going to be
something different
we're going to build on what we did last
year so uh staff are currently working
with wacom builders
and we're identifying uh
some potential speakers and supports for
a series
so we talk about the terrible three
three that affect particularly men and
youth who are over represented in
statistics in our community for
mental health and suicide issues
family violence family harm
and
alcohol-related harmoner depiction
so what we're looking at doing is
bringing together a series that
addresses those three areas
initially in the trade sector but also
looking at how we can offer that in some
of our more rural communities
i'm very pleased to hear that because i
know the trade sector has been very
important but also
some of the other rural areas you know
it's like in the farming and things like
that that we need to be focusing on as
well so thank you very much for that
thank you and it's about meeting them uh
it's about making sure that we're
relevant and that we're we're uh able to
work and networks with men are likely
together
thank you
all right is there anyone else
i've got a question
um
tessa i i've been
privileged i guess to to take part in
quite a number of these projects that
you've got here and i really have the
utmost respect for you and your team and
and what they're doing out there and it
really is making a difference
one of the things that i have been
involved with is the alcohol and drug
steering group which you'd be aware we
are missing our wonderful staff member
who has left us um is there a
replacement forth coming for her yes
there is and i've got i have martin
covering uh because he has a few spare
hours currently so i've got money
he's got plenty to do but i've been able
to nab him for an extra day to cover
that uh for the time being
and we've
we've put it out there to our networks
that this role will be coming up so we
don't expect to drop service delivery
right
and do we have any idea when we might
look to replace
that particular yeah i would imagine
that with the
going through the recruitment process we
would have someone on board by the end
of april
and martin will cover the mean time
great
um and also just you mentioned in in
your report about the
communication from the cdhp and i'm not
sure or a good person to ask or maybe
dan um just i've heard out in the
community there
is ongoing concern about cuts to home
care and there's also that question that
there's been rather poor communication
about the oxford hospital closure as far
as you know before how long what time
frame is and um you know who the
communication
points are
um
for instance the oxford community trust
would very much like to know
what's going on there and haven't been
able to actually get anybody to come
back to them with their questions so do
you know
anything about that or where we can
point them
um i'm happy to give that a shot with
that's right
so i got a phone call
at two weeks ago from john hanson to
advise that in the interim they were
um
a temporary closure of oxford hospital
which was a surprise but not a surprise
in terms of the context of omicron
so um you've seen the advocacy that we
have done since which is
basically there was a at leisure i
encouraged to come to the merrill county
mural forum um because it's not just
ours there's four
across um a number of districts
uh and then a joint statement from there
murray burke and myself we want to see
the hospital reopened as soon as
possible and we were wasting a response
from sir john we've also sent that to
the minister of health
um because actually it's not that far
away before the cdhb transitions to the
new
health new zealand model whatever that's
going to look like we're not entirely
clear
at this point
i've i've heard those concerns around
perhaps health care in general i've
asked for people if they can get
specific examples so we can check that
through because every time i've asked
that question i'm told that there isn't
an issue so
in including through gray power so
if people are noticing that out in the
community home care there is issues
please get those cases through so we can
get those followed through because i'm
advised there is no it there is no cut
in that respect so i would really like
to know where they are and then we can
feed those through our contacts
this stage expecting oxford hospital to
be reopened as soon as possible um
because there are a number of people
that really want to see that and i'd
rather that happen so it doesn't become
a
decision of a wellington-based
bureaucrat that won't have the same
connection to our community here jim and
i both took sir john hanson
the cdhb chair along with tessa out to
oxford last year just pressed how
important those hospitals are and health
care are in our community so
if we have to continue that with a new
new model comes about we'll make sure
that we do but i'm connected through the
regional leadership group which meets
every thursday and we're continuing to
press those issues so if there's any
cases as i say let me know so we can
raise those uh through those forums that
we're connected with so dan just just to
clarify then so people that have issues
should raise them directly to you
well they should raise it with through
their doctor actually and through cdh
but if they're not getting anywhere you
know i'm more than happy to
pick those up and take them through the
context we've got but if they you know
the first instance it should always be
through their gp and existing service
but if they're not giving the answers or
satisfaction then really like to know so
we can feed those through and get those
reviewed
because we get answers pretty quickly on
those things
great thank you so much
tessa you wanted to add to that
um yes i just wanted to say that that's
something that we'll raise again via our
networks it is a really odd one the the
the lack of service provision it through
the various stages of covert you get you
get holed up so the lockdowns mean that
the housekeeping might not happen for a
while and then it comes back on board
and it may be that they have staff
resourcing issues
um i i gather that some of that had been
reversed so uh but i'll certainly raise
it at social services why am i careering
through the older person's networks
thank you tessa
right is there anything further to add
ladies and gentlemen
okay so we have
a mover and wendy do we have someone to
second the recommendations
oh philip
sorry robbie
okay um wendy would you like to speak to
the recommendations yes thank you very
much chief that that was that that was a
very good report and um i appreciate um
the questions that have been answered
and i would just like to say about the
oxford hospital that the um
the client the clients that have
had to be moved on from there there was
two of them when i was 98 and 99
pretty tough and they'd lived all their
lives in oxford so it's pretty tough to
have to be moving them out like that the
other thing that we came up that was
which was really
something that the dhb had not even
considered was the amount of home
meals that are produced by the oxford
hospital
and they just thought they could uh
perhaps contact one of the local
businesses to do this service well my
brain
meals for
ordinary adults and meals for elderly
people are two very different things but
fortunately they've suddenly come
unrealised as what an enormous thing
that was around all the dhbs that they
decided
that needed to be have their clients
taken away from
um as so now we're actually keeping
those going so that's a really good
win-win situation for that so
the staff
the
cooking staff are staying on and doing
the meals on wheels so that's really
pleasing
thank you
thank you andy and phillip
uh
thank you madam chair uh i'll just
concur with
hb visited
peter bramley said when talking about
bricks and mortar
in relation to oxford that
they were thinking of
they weren't thinking closing services
but they were considering other ways of
delivering them in the traditional way
through bricks and mortar might not
necessarily be what they come up with
so i think they've had these rural
hospitals on their radar for some time
so
there may be a different way of
providing the services rather than
having specific buildings but
personally i think locals would prefer
to have a facility and uh as wendy said
if they're cooking meals out there um
that's a good reason to retain it
thank you
thanks philip and philip change that
smoke alarm
and it's not going the battery's flat
maybe i should come and sort it out for
you
just for the record i have purchased new
batteries which just sitting on my bench
i just haven't installed them do it
again
all right thanks philip dan
okay i'm just to say report uh support
the report and look i couldn't have been
prouder of tessa
last thursday when she presented um to
the regional leadership group
um which involved all the canterbury
years and
all their experts well sorry all the
um dpm department of prime minister and
cabinet and ministry of health officials
on effectively the model that had been
developed
here at the waimakariri level in
partnership with msd
and so you know anyone could have been
asked to have presented there but they
chose waimakariri and that's due to the
work that tessa and the team have done
and preparing our community with a an
appropriate covered response the
well-done test so i just wanted to
acknowledge
you for
this and was delighted to um to see you
on that call
um just on the oxford hospital what's
been said but look it's 100 years old
it's had a friends of oxford hospital
ever since its start they have raised a
fortune for that place to keep it going
um new cursions new tvs care of patients
carers that come in there uh in families
so
there's a huge investment uh from our
community in that space i don't think
there's so much consumed necessarily if
if the facility is no longer fit for
purpose
but a new one comes along but they need
to be kept in touch with what is the
thinking
and
the communication from cdhb is just not
very good in that space
and they don't keep the friends in touch
are dealing with a new person all the
time
and that's the frustration that comes
about from those really really keen
bunch and meals on wheels of mindy said
as a prime example of that
just not understanding so once john
called i said make sure the friends are
called and told please and so they're
well informed but linda herrera and the
team out there do a fantastic job and
we're keeping connected with them to
keep them supported but the provision of
health and the delivery of health in our
community is really really important and
um i just also want to acknowledge all
our team
they've assisted getting us
a collection site out here um because
that too is important that we have those
things at this time
delivered in our communities and we're
not expecting people to drive into town
for that vital service so thanks to
chris
and all the rest of the team that were
in the lotus it was lobbying hard too
and grant and
andy coca did a really great job getting
it over the line to support our
community so there's a
there's a lot going on in this space
not only through pieces and reporting
here of our support for together
but that just that wider connection that
supports our community really proud that
we've got this team working as hard as
they do do a fantastic job here so thank
you
having having witnessed firsthand in the
the
coveted welfare committee and various
other groups that you've pulled together
and seen the waimakariri way as i've
seen your report we've actually got a
name for it um we are immensely proud of
you and your team of legends and what
they've been able to deliver to our
communities and um i thank you for your
ongoing hard work
and your dedication to the people that
live here so
with that i will put this to the vote
the recommendations a through f
all in favor raise your hand
opposed
i wouldn't think so right
that's past thank you so much tessa and
keep up the fantastic work and pass the
bouquets on to your team
thank you
next up we have
matt
greenwood with the
aquatics update
come on brown matt
thanks madam chair woman person um
the so the purpose of this report is to
provide the council's community and
recreation committee with a summary of
aquatic facilities here to date against
our key indicators i'll take the report
as read but wish to highlight a couple
of key issues
so following assessment of our standard
operating procedures and other core
documents in a day of on-site audits by
an external
assessor the aquatic facilities were
once again credited with pool safe
status so poolsafe is our industry best
practice um
setting with which ensures robust
process and health and safety policies
to ensure that our customers have a safe
and enjoyable place to to come and
recreate
as highlighted in 4.1 attendance
6.1 financial and issue 4.3 the team
continues to work hard to maximize
opportunities however requirements at
covid's red setting
involves a lot of community spread and
isolation requirements and this
continues to impact customer numbers
across the business
while we've largely been able to juggle
staffing so that programs and services
continue to operate under unaffected
our staff resources also limited and
being stretched by that those same
isolation requirements
this is a as as we all know this is a
constantly changing environment with
weekly changes and updates to guidance
which affects our facilities but also
often
uh highlight differences of
understanding and those same guidance
which need to be clarified
uh we continue to monitor this and
ensure we maximize the opportunities for
our
local
customers and and the and ensure we
provide a safe
opportunity for recreation
and this brings us to 4.4 staffing our
staff resources stretched in at the
moment and it is
as it is with most
facilities within our industry and a
number of similar
sized local employers
as detailed in the report we are part
way through our second recruitment since
christmas with the aim of bringing on a
number of
new staff to help bolster the ranks
further to this report as council's
aware we recently announced that we'll
be temporarily running limited hours at
kaiapoi aquatic centre by closing the
facility early over the weekends we'll
be able to better utilize those
available staff resources at a time when
we can see more customers keen to use
the facilities this will was not a step
that we took lightly however it is in
line with steps taken by neighboring
councils with christchurch
to name one closing a number of pools
and other facilities daily
to end on a bright note in our most
recent customer satisfaction survey we
achieved an overall customer
satisfaction rating of 91
while this is down from the previous
result of 96
it exceeds the target of 90
especially when considering what a
challenging environment we're currently
operating in
um as always i'm happy to take any
all questions thank you matt for that
very comprehensive report
um is there anyone out there with
questions oh there is wendy i think
matt thank you very much for this report
um and i
appreciate the the difficult situation
that you've been through with um trying
to get started
um how ha and i appreciate also
the uh the
the information that you pass on to the
users of the pool how have you got on
with the oxford one with having to close
a fairly
um we we only closed for a day up at
oxford and padam
yeah thank you oh yes yeah sorry so we
only had to close for a day up at oxford
then we were able to reopen that was
just due to a
sickness on the day um we had a staff
member who um turned up
um
it actually turned up to work sick
despite our uh guidance tool staff to
not
show up to work sick so we scrambled and
managed to get something in place uh
just to see the current customers that
were in the facility um out and then we
had to we weren't able to find anyone at
short notice so reopen the following day
thank you so are you going to you hope
to be able to keep that going or do you
think you might have to shorten the term
the time so we've now closed for the
season um we closed on the on the
weekend um we we have a number of plans
in the works uh for next season already
um we plan to uh do a bit more work
earlier on in the year approaching the
high school um one of the benefits of
our current training program is it's
unit standards based so for people who
are
in 16 years olds that's generally
seventh form
we have the opportunity to um add to
their their education and unit standard
accreditation um and get them some unit
standards that they can actually use and
flow on into a job in the community so
we're hoping to identify uh people who
will be around for the next couple of
years potentially three or four and feed
make sure we're hiring those local staff
who actually live in the community and
don't have to travel from the other side
of town or what have you
thank you mark
thank you matt i'm cool
hey there matt um i'm a little bit
concerned but um
we haven't got that much robust in there
before the private side of the thing
here and we're still striving for staff
are we actually going out to the public
advertising and seeing the people that
got these qualifications that sitting
back
that
are very swimming people and that would
probably like to um
be on a call situation but they don't
want a permanent job or anything like
that but
you know just to fill in these spaces
when we get in the situation like that
because
there's a lot of life savers in our area
and and adult ones as well younger ones
but
are we approaching these people and
getting out there um
because we need the help um quite frank
frankly and then we need to be robust
and i don't think that's um
prudent and doesn't look good when we
have to close the facility particularly
a swimming pool
um because of a staffing shortages and
staff are out here
and a lot of them would volunteer for
that thing i know that because they i've
talked to some of them and
how are we getting out to the public
great question yeah so we have um we've
advertised we've spoken to a lot of the
surf uh people as well um unfortunately
um a lot of the interests was served for
people under 16. um our requirements
around poolsafe is that that the
individuals need to be 16 years or over
to to
meet the requirement acquired standard
for supervising younger swimmers
we've we've been we advertised out on
seek
all the standard council places seek
the council's website our facebook pages
council's facebook page
me jobs uh recreational
um
skills active um we contacted a number
of the high schools through our hr team
and and advertised there as well um and
of of this most recent employment we we
did get maybe around 20 applicants
however as as you're aware there is
there is a balance between finding a
person to fill a job and taking on
potentially a candidate who is not a
good fit
um so we we need to continue to work
through those situations to make sure
that we're we're taking on robust
candidates who are able to to meet the
requirements of the role and live the
council values yeah
um chris would you like to say something
to that
yeah if i could just add um the impact
that we're having at the moment we
already had a bit of an issue in the
industry with the amount of people that
we could actually get um to be
lifeguards um but we but we're doing
lots to try the issue at the moment with
closing facilities is directly related
to um covert um christchurch has shut
entire pools they've got two shut at the
moment and they've got various parts of
other pools closed at the moment um
we're getting people ringing us on a
constant basis asking if we can lend
them stuff
so so it's not just us it's everybody in
the industry at the moment if paul
you've got people who
you think are suitable then absolutely
pass on
their details to us and we can have
conversations with them about them being
a casual um to be called on or or them
being a permanent employee but
we've asked lots and lots and lots of
people in lots of different areas but
it's going to get worse
in terms of the impact of covert and and
not being able to call on those staff
because of the fact that we have people
isolating at home um before it gets uh
any better that's just the reality we
face
yeah and thanks for that yeah and i
actually had passed names on to um met
before i met my concerns are the way
we're advertising it seemed to me we
were actually after people who want
employment work and jobs there are some
people there who would actually probably
volunteer that's quite qualified if we
hit that type of market for an emergency
situation for
one or two or three days in a row for
needed that's the type of people i
reckon we should be targeting as well as
the the workforce um
some people would love to volunteer but
i want to be faithful in that type of
work because they are interested in
education of our children for swimming
and all that grammar so
it's a different avenue probably what
we're targeting for
employment that's all thank you you send
them to us buddy
all right um philip
sorry guys i just realized the time
we've got another meeting starting here
in another um
23 minutes so
that that was a good long question paul
um
and i should also say i was a pull
attendant to kaiapoy in the early 80s
but i'm sorry matt i had the intention
of returning
um matt what issues has the covert
passport mandate brought to your
business in terms of staffing and
patronage have you noticed issues
related to that aspect
um it would be difficult to split out
the issues directly related to my
vaccine passport and those directly
related to you know like
numbers from people who are
uncomfortable about being in the
community around covert there there is a
trend of downward numbers as people
isolate and so it would be difficult to
split those out specifically however we
do get a lot of feedback from from
customers who
uh unhappy with the council's position
as um
as uh some of them have gone i see the
mayor's no longer here but that's all
right i'm sure he would back me up um
and i'm sure the councillors are also
receiving feedback from the community
about people who aren't quite happy with
our position however
it is important to note there's also a
large number of people who are very
supportive of our position around
my vaccine pass and when um and when we
brought it in were very vocal about
especially at the facilities about the
fact that they felt comfortable knowing
that council were taking the appropriate
steps to ensure that people within the
business uh within the facility sorry uh
of a you know vaccinated and creating a
safe environment however i do appreciate
that going forward this is also a
changing environment and we are
transitioning as a community to living
with with a macron and and covert and
all of that so it is a a an ongoing
moving target um and we we try to
address those as they come up um and
ensure that we continue to to follow the
the current stan required standard by
the by the ministry of health and the
government
well
would it be helping ordinary ability
itself
i didn't that was a
can you maybe turn your camera off i
think that was the the mad trick that
uh i've been having trouble today along
with others i think um does the covert
passport uh that helping or hindering
you staff
oh staff right yes yes um uh it's not
actually uh making a huge effect we we
have uh we've had to enter into
discussions with two staff members
around um around vaccine past
and their continued work however um
the
new we've we put that we require vaccine
where a vaccine pass required facility
on the advert and the numbers of
applicants were working
up there with what we normally see so
yeah i wouldn't say it it impacts um it
impacts our ability to go out and
recruit new staff no
thank you
um there are a series of recommendations
here folks um and just in the interest
of time um is there somebody that would
like to
move that they be received
yes
l and seconded by robbie sorry
okay
so
just putting that to the vote um all in
favor
aye
and
opposed
thank you that's passed
thank you so much matt for a very
comprehensive report in what our very
trying times you're doing amazingly and
yeah keep your chin up hopefully we'll
get out of this sometime soon um you're
doing a great job as are your team so
thank you thank you for your work to the
community
um and moving on to our last report of
the day we have paula
with her library update come on down
paula
thank you very much uh kyoto this report
will provide the council's community and
recreation committee with an update from
december the 2nd to march the 3rd
and i'd like to highlight quickly
several points from within the report
can i draw your attention to 4.1
new library cards so waimakariri library
members new and existing will soon be
able to choose from four unique designs
when joining the local libraries
this artwork as i like to call it
is the brainchild of creative admin
administrator lucas
ferdinand ferdinand
and he's done a wonderful piece of work
in conjunction with three of the library
team
on how the libraries the district
libraries would like to represent the
district and the four in in library
cards um and available are four new
cards that you'll see in the report
so we have y
water
we have
fenua
the lands
[Music]
we have tangata
the people
and we have
only the towns and you'll see on the
cards there's a
fold-out piece that can be ripped off
and then that becomes on your key ring
your library card that you travel around
with all the time
so
the previous cards
were
examples like this
or this
so you can see it's quite a reinvention
of library cards
um
the new cards
are where we've tried to as the
diversity of the district grows to have
a diverse range of cards that people can
choose with the
vision that people can see themselves in
the library cards we will be running a
new campaign
called one card endless possibilities
once the cards are out of manufacturing
stage
the library's team has been really
committed to trying to keep as much of
our business as local as possible and
the local supplier authenticate limited
have been awarded the contract for this
and they were offering a rate
substantially less than um
all of the competition
uh we have timed it so that the existing
library cards will almost be out of
stock to reduce as much waste as
possible and anybody who already has one
of the old cards but would like one of
the new cards will be able to purchase
one for two dollars so we hope that
creates a little bit of energy
if i now look at 4.2
so over previous reports i've requested
permission and so instead of ideas for
how we can use the existing space at
bangor library while we wait for the
extension um
towards the end of 2028 2030. um just to
give you an update there has been
consultation with all vendors um in
regard to sheldon
and in regards to kiosk replacements
and
there will be a report to the council's
management team around the tender
contract for those as there are only two
main players for both within new zealand
libraries are receiving a lot of support
from the communities facilities team um
and we are now waiting on a formal quote
to remove the now obsolete radiators in
rangiora library so that we're able to
maximize the available floor space
as we
uh reef
we adjust the layout of the library with
the new shelving
the citizens advice office soon to be
the library technology
and learning hub is
has been scoped for work and we're just
awaiting the contractor to do that
um and we have been working with sewing
libraries through our nz lpp contacts
around what sort of technology and
programs we'll be offering in that space
i wanted to flag in 4.2.5
that was as with many supply chains
across new zealand at the moment
our supply chains continue to be
disrupted with shelving contractors
saying that steel
for shelving
is has us quite a delay if this was
likely to cross a financial year i would
flag this in an upcoming report
and finally 4.5
just looking at library services at red
so last time i reported to you was pre
my vaccine passes pre-alert level
read
i've been absolutely humbled and just so
proud of my team and the way that they
have responded to turning our services
um online as much as possible so once
again the programming team from the
preschool team the toddler time team and
the baby times team have taken their
videos um online right down to creating
original content because the waivers
around copyright have not have not um
been maintained
um at elite level read
february was beerui on facebook with
featured videos of goldilocks story
times and original content um and reuse
of content that is outside of copyright
i'd just like to say that it's been a
really big change for my team as i've
embraced that idea of copyright
compliance i um content out of copyright
so there's been a lot of learning on the
fly to get that content up there
um the craft clubs which were just
proving so popular were taken online
straight away
with also a craft pack called take and
make and as of this morning the the
corresponding video to the video to the
craft pack that is available at all
three libraries has had uh 326 views and
57 free craft packs taken um this this
last month click and collect services
continue to be very well utilized in
particular those with from those without
a vaccine pass
when the library receives a request for
items
via our inbox
books are issued and placed in a
reusable
paper brown paper bag shopping
supermarket bag and they're placed
outside in the foyer of each library for
the individual or the whanau to collect
some members of our community have large
families or specific needs so we've
created a service of a personalized
librarian like you have a personal
shopper to do your grocery shopping
we'll have a personal shopper to support
these people i had an incident uh with a
very disgruntled person who presented um
an alternative vaccine passed that was
not a correct one um and after talking
with her through her needs i assigned
her a staff member who was willing and
and there was a good connection got an
email on sunday that said from the
customer from the member of the
community
i still have two books left to read but
i would i'll be out of reading by next
weekend i'd really appreciate it if you
could organize another eight or ten
books for me please i have thoroughly
read enjoyed reading all of the books
you've chosen for me one good thing
about having someone else doing the
selecting for me is i get to read a
wider variety of authors
i have a habit of going to the recently
returned shelves and any author whose
name i recognize as having enjoyed
reading previously i just grab
you've introduced me to many authors
i've not heard of i'll leave it in your
hands totally again thank you so much
for being my personal librarian and that
was shared for my team
from them what could have been another
quite fractured
interaction with somebody who wasn't
able to access the library
we've got a new reading club book club
brewing called fiction addiction which
is um in development stages which will
hopefully create a another way for
people to connect virtually in that
well-being building on what we did in
the first lockdown with our book bubble
book groups
i will stop there as i know time is
short but happy to take any questions
have you got any questions team
okay um
in the interest of tom my friends do we
have a mover and a secondary for our
recommendation
moved by wendy seconded by al
would you like to speak to that
thank you very much uh very paul i
appreciate your uh really good report
and it's so interesting reading willie
the work that you and your staff are
doing so well done i'm sorry with this
time bit short but
a hundred thousand thank yous
now yeah thanks paula nothing to add
hello i'm always a fan you and your team
of library stars never cease to amaze me
with the great work that they do
um so i thank you for that thank you for
a great report and the
what is business as usual your amazing
work in the library space so thank you
to your team i'll put that to a vote
all in favor
recommendations a through c
opposed i declare that past thank you
thanks very much paula and um have a
lovely rest of your afternoon
now going back to our agenda here
um
we've got some
matters for information
the maria andrews toilet block upgrade
and carpark tender evaluation somebody
to move that we receive that
robbie seconded by phillip all in favor
raise a hand
opposed right declare that carried
portfolio updates green space robbie
yep
yep so very very briefly um
as you're aware with this red light
things clubs are straight struggling as
far as
knowing when they can
put a team on the field our staff have
been
working with many codes to try and
facilitate but unfortunately the rules
keep changing frequently which is
causing frustration
fernside hall car park ceiling is now
complete
the rest of the car park when you're
programmed to start shortly with
complication at the end of april milton
memorial reserve tree clearance has been
completed work on additional items
including fencing is being programmed in
staff were reviewing uh forecasts on
projects given the low turnout
from the market
um and as an example of
this
we tended for uh some some work
unfortunately the tender came back in
overpriced and will be re-tended again
so some of the things that were
programmed uh
may not be completed because of the
market contract uh condition so that's
me very briefly grant sorry i really
summarized the stuff that you gave me
thanks very much robbie any questions
there
no okay and
moving to wendy your community
facilities and community development and
well-being
i do apologize but with me
in my
blocks of
two houses and trying to move i'm afraid
i just haven't done that
okay
i do apologize
this is the perfect meeting for that to
happen because we're running very short
on time so that's fine thank you
um and al arts and culture
yeah thank you i'll be brief too um
why pat had a very successful
sunday afternoon
fundraiser and get to know us meeting a
couple of weeks ago kaipoy expo have
very made a very generous donation out
of their profits
why pat and we're we're um running down
a
a sculptor to give make us a sculpture
that goes somewhere in rangiora um ma
the marshall family in ahoka have their
gift of their sculpture has now been
installed in the ohoka domain
the oxford mural on the toilet's walls
there that has all been finalized and
approved by ypat and it'll be going to
the community board for final approval
before the the local artist starts work
on that the pose at the mouth at the
gateway of
pegasus have been completed if you've
seen them in their shiny new paint and
that's me
wonderful thank you so much al
um and no questions i presume so we were
meant to have a briefing about a couple
issues um we are probably running a bit
short on time for that
um
so chris you said
yeah go ahead uh yeah so i understand
that you've got a
meeting with environment canada to talk
about annual planned stuff which was uh
moved in in terms of timing that's
absolutely fine mandeville stockpile a
lot of people we just heard a report
about that earlier on today so people
are relatively briefed about that one
yeah
sorry
are we recording still are we streaming
uh yeah we will be yep um and then the
ranger at airfield um we've got a an
update on that as well but what we'll do
is we'll just get a memo together um or
an email and we'll just send out details
to councillors um on on both of those
especially the ranger at airfield one
which um a couple of councillors will be
aware of but
not everybody so we'll just give you
that in writing and then you can come
back to us with any questions if you
want
great thanks very much for that
chris um
all right guys as we are hot on the
heels of another meeting in about three
minutes um i
seriously
excuse me madam chair
we've got if we can quickly go we've got
a public excluded item that's at the end
of the agenda
if we can close the meeting recording
uh yes please dubious
here
i
record her or she
can't see her
let's see recorder
we can leave it
a few
if everybody is in agreements we can
hold it over until the next meeting
we have agreement team
yes yep okay yeah that's fine adrian
right
so
without further ado if i may
i hereby declare them meeting closed
at 2 58 and the next meeting of the
community recreation committee is
scheduled for 3 30 p.m on tuesday the
31st of may
thank you everyone for your
participation and your great work
see you later and see you in about two
minutes hey um adria adrian
oh she could be going
here yeah um uh dan's just rung me and
asked me to chair this coming meeting
because he's his plans have all gone to
hell um i don't know can you open the
book can you open the um zoom for me no
no
sorry i think we'll have to it might be
under a different zoom i'm not sure what
tia does all that side of things okay
tia will do it for me
i can't open it from here
oh okay um i'm not sure
i don't think i have it
we had an email a day or two ago from
tia with the link oh yeah okay have you
got that now i've got that yeah but do i
have to do anything to invite people in
no she will do that i think everyone
should
everyone should be able to get them in
themselves okay yeah thank you okay bye
yes
[Music]
you